if you're looking to buy a block of land
regardless if it's for your next home
your dream home or even just the
development today's video will focus on
the key criteria you need to understand
to basically be able to purchase the
best block of land possible for you
what's going on guys welcome back to the
channel for those of you who don't know
me my name is david thomich i'm a
registered architect here in western
australia and today is a very very
special video not only are we filming in
a brand new set with two brand new
computers behind me we'll get to that
later we're also filming on a wednesday
so moving forward we're going to be
producing two videos a week one on
monday one on wednesday and these
wednesday videos are going to be a
little bit more of a general knowledge
information from my background as an
architect and how i can help you to be
able to better yourselves in that sector
so if you're looking for anything
architecture related this video every
single wednesday is exactly where you're
going to find it so in today's video
we're talking about buying lands and
we're talking about buying land
specifically in australia but it is
transferable across the world because
the principles are very much the same so
when you're looking to buy your block of
land obviously the first thing you want
to be looking at is your actual budget
your budget is going to define which
piece of land you can buy and which
piece of land you can't buy it's very
very simple and it doesn't really matter
what block of land you're looking at
that is going to be the number one
critical factor that changes everything
and will sway you to one block
potentially over another however when we
take out the factor of any sort of
budget constraints we can actually talk
about the fundamental architectural
principles that you really should be
looking out for and looking into to be
able to purchase the best block of land
to be able to build the best possible
thing on that bit of land so let's start
with the solar orientation solar
orientation basically in australia you
want to be looking for a block of land
that is elongated in such a way that the
north side is on the longest side
now because a lot of properties in
australia are very long and skinny that
means you want to be basically looking
at a block of land that faces the
longest length to north so that your
living areas can be proportioned on the
north side this basically allows you to
heat up your whole living spaces
throughout the day
naturally using the sun and keep your
southern side for your private sleeping
quarters which are generally designed to
be in a cooler climate and a cooler
condition compared to the living space
so you can basically sleep a lot more
comfortably at night time if you can
find a block of land that is perfectly
positioned with the long side facing
north this is the first thing that you
can tick off the list now when you've
found the block of land you want to also
make sure there's no restrictions on
that black land so as an example on this
block of land that i'm sitting on right
now there's a four and a half meter
easement to the back of the property for
all sewer services which basically means
i can't build anything over those last
four and a half meters except grass
bricks and maybe some sort of paving
anything that isn't permanent and can be
simply removed upon request chances are
if you're watching this video you're
probably either looking at building your
first residential home or your next
residential home most people looking to
build their dream residential home have
already built a feud so they know what's
going on in australia if you're looking
to purchase your first block of land
there's a lot of things that are
continuous across the board and you
really really want to make sure you're
aware of before you commit to any
blocker land so the prime example blocks
the land go up for sale in australia all
the time however what they don't tell
you is that every block of land is
subject to the r codes the residential
codes of either western australia
victoria new south wales or whatever
state you fall under most likely these
residential codes are applicable all
over the world so it is still applicable
to anybody around the world watching
this video one thing to keep in mind is
the fact that a block of land zoned r40
as an example has certain restrictions
of how close you can build to the
boundary you can't go ahead and build
boundary to boundary on all four corners
and just take up a hundred percent of
that land most of the time you either
have to have a certain amount of outdoor
living space which cuts it down to 40 of
usable or 60 unusable land depending
which way you want to look at it it also
cuts down how close to the boundary can
be at any given time and how far back
from the street you have to be
so imagine you bought a block of land 10
meters wide 20 meters long and all of a
sudden you have to come in two meters
from both sides and get pushed back six
meters from the street
you now have a 14 metre wide block by a
six meter wide block that you can
effectively build on this is something
you really really want to take into
consideration before you make any
commitments because if you can't fit
your dream home or your next home in
those restrictions that are already
presented to you you might be in trouble
an easement or any sort of restriction
isn't the be-all end-all it is just
something that you want to be aware of
at the very very start rather than
finding out halfway through the process
when you start the discussion with your
architect and they flag a big five metre
easement in the back of your property
and say oh sorry you've just lost 10
percent of your land that you paid x
amount of dollars for on top of that if
you're buying a block of land off the
plan and have no idea what it's going to
look like sight unseen you want to read
that plan or the developers marketing
plan as best as you possibly can there's
a couple things to watch out for first
of all you want to watch out for any
story limits if you want to build a
two-story three-story or even more story
house be sure you can do that on that
block of land in that area
there are some blocks that are zoned
specifically for one story single story
residents some must be two-story which
means you're spending even more money
that you may not be prepared for
or they could have a whole bunch of
other restrictions you also need to be
very very careful and very vigilant
about the block you pick based on where
the light poles are the street trees are
the power dome is going to go and
potentially even where they might
restrict you to put your garage so if
you're restricted to put your garage at
the very back or the very right hand
side of the property this might not work
with what you're trying to achieve so
again it is something that you have to
be very vigilant about and very cautious
of before you commit to purchasing any
blocker land and being caught out the
last thing i want to bring up is bush
fire attack levels now australia has
unfortunately been plagued with numerous
bushfires over the last couple of years
increasing rapidly thanks to climate
change and it is something that we are
all unfortunately going to have to live
with the more and more life progresses
and the more and more we push out into
the bush means we're getting closer and
closer to the bush there are new
regulations called bal or bushfire
attack level regulations that play a
part in the overall block of land
sometimes developers will subdivide a
whole block of land into multiple little
pieces and some bits are right against
that bush which means is exactly what
you're looking for but it might also
increase the construction cost
unfortunately for you in the process
so there's a number of bushfire attack
levels to be mindful of first of all
balo or nobel
is the cheapest and most common that we
are building to in australia
bell 12 and a half bow 19 and bow 29 are
all reasonably acceptable with bow 29
being the highest that we are generally
allowed to build in unless there is
absolutely no other option and then we
really get into the bush land and we get
into the midst of it when we go to bow
40 and the bell fz the bell flame zone
any of these blocks of land will incur
significantly higher construction costs
than what you might be expecting because
they require a safety factor on them
that is simply going to increase the
cost of construction regardless of how
you do it there is no way to basically
build a standard kit home directly in a
flame zone and hope for the best but it
won't be legally allowed you're going to
have to spend a significant amount of
more money to be able to actually
construct to those regulations so if
you're looking at an off the plan grid
and you're looking at all of the
properties available to you
some of them might be pinged as
balo bal29 bow 40 or anything in between
you really want to be looking for the
lowest bow rating or no bail rating at
all if it is possible in your situation
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below and don't forget about the
like button if you have any questions
leave them in the comments down below i
will answer as many as i possibly can